let's talk about what's going on with
Roy Moore and I guess the way I would
summarize it is things are not going
well for Roy Moore now in the wake of
multiple sexual assault allegations
against him by teenagers the Republican
National Committee has completely pulled
out of Roy Moore or I guess better said
they've pulled support for their
campaign Pat is not liking some of the
phraseology I'm using here they've
pulled their support for their campaign
get your minds out of the gutter the
joint fundraising agreement that they
had with Roy Moore sort of similar to
the Hillary Clinton agreement with the
DNC in fact they're canceling that
agreement they are cancelling their
field program to help Roy Moore out
before the special election scheduled
for December 12th
they are basically done putting any
money into Roy Moore's campaign and then
every senator who had endorsed Roy Moore
except for Rand Paul has also pulled
their endorsements including even
depraved degenerate Ted Cruz says I am
no longer endorsing Roy Moore only Rand
Paul has yet to rescind his endorsement
of Roy Moore we don't know if it's
because he's got the broken ribs and
it's just not dealing with politics not
really true because he's been tweeting
about all the other stuff we don't know
here is Ted Cruz's statement these
allegations are deeply concerning we've
now seen multiple I even when I read it
in my voice I'm hearing it in Ted Cruz's
weird nasally voice oh it's like we've
now seen multiple serious allegations of
criminal conduct one of two things
should happen if these allegations are
true judge Moore should drop out now
today the people of Alabama deserve to
have the option of voting for a strong
conservative who has not committed
criminal conduct or two if these
allegations are not true than judge
Moore needs to come forward with strong
persuasive rebuttal demonstrating that
they are untrue as it stands tonight the
people of Alabama are faced with an
untenable choice and so it is my hope
one of these two options will occur very
very quickly going on to say I am NOT
able to urge the people of Alabama to
support his candidacy so long as these
allegations remain unrefuted both last
week and this week there are serious
charges of criminal conduct that if true
not only make him unfit to serve in the
Senate but marriage criminal prosecution
judge more like any American is entitled
to present a defense he's entitled to
put
facts demonstrating the charges are not
true but as it stands I can't urge the
people of Alabama to support a campaign
in the face of these charges without
serious persuasive demonstration that
the charges are not true do not for a
second think that these Republicans like
Ted Cruz who are pulling their support
are pulling their support because they
think it is morally the right thing to
do they are doing it because they see it
as the right move for self-preservation
for credibility and for their own
political careers that is all and at a
certain point you have to decide which
side of the keurig revolution you're on
it's basically that simple right you're
either a lot a liberal or you're a
French press communist or you are a
cappuccino conservative I don't know
what I'm talking about but the point is
the Keurig thing is kind of a sidebar
but you do have to decide do you want to
vote for a guy in Alabama if you are
voting in this race who has multiple
credible allegations against him of
child sexual assault or do you want to
say it doesn't matter the politics this
person does not deserve nor should they
be in the US Senate I'm wondering how
this all plays into Steve bannon's war
against the establishment pulling Jeff
Sessions out of the Senate to be a
troubled compulsively lying Attorney
General which frees up this seat in
Alabama for an alleged serial child sex
abusers to become the focal point of
really damaging media coverage but still
and this is why we can't let up Roy
Moore might win Roy Moore won't might
win and that's why you need to get
involved yesterday if not right now
phone bank donate knock on doors if
you're in Alabama get involved I know
that Mitch McConnell has said that if
Roy Moore wins the Senate could just
choose not to seat him I think that that
is BS I think that once if and when Roy
Moore wins the Senate will say well
listen the people have spoken and we're
going to allow him to serve you need to
get involved and I am hoping that
Alabamans will do the right thing here
because this could easily end up with
Republican senators denouncing more or
pulling their endorse
Donald Trump continuing to stay silent
which he's been throughout and since
returning from his Asia trip more
winning and then we basically forget
about the entire thing do not let it
happen get involved in this race however
you can however you want to you don't
have to have money you can phone bank
here if you're not able to donate do it
we've got to take the seat okay Doug
Jones is the guy david pakman.com slash
read it discuss it with us we'll be back
after this today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS